once there was an abomination who had no
place in this world
a dragon crossbreed feared by the gods
and described as an antithesis to all
life clutching a strange doll and truly
alone
eventually this pale white haired girl
was drawn into a cold and lonely painted
world and much later perhaps within many
layers of these painted worlds a scaled
snake eyed yong-go becomes the last hope
for Humanity we've talked at length
already about the paintings but it bears
repeating basically they're
self-contained universes that exist
within themselves and from what we can
gather the original in the overworld is
the painted world of ariamis in Anor
Londo which is protected by the painting
Guardians and as any painting does
really these paintings reflect the
themes of the outside world with a cycle
of death and rebirth
just like our world so inevitably just
like the flame will fade a painting will
become rotten and when this happens the
residents make the decision to set their
world aflame then escaping into yet
another painted world as their world
burns behind them so that they can live
on human I cannot die I have a world to
paint this painter has no name so we've
taken to calling her aria and to paint a
new world she must see flame those who
aren't Kenta fire cannot paint a world
those absorbed by fire must not paint a
world don't worry I haven't forgotten
another so just as her mother was once
shown flame Aria too must have an
awareness of it so in our fight with
another unn kindled Freda the friction
of our clash sets the world aflame yet
aria is left wanting for one more thing
ashin one that gift of flame has taken
root and uncle Gail will soon bring the
pigment pigment colored like the dark
soul of man since the dark soul of man
has never been retrieved from the Ring
City it follows that are painting with
this dark soul as the pigment will be
different than the paintings before it I
wish to paint a picture of the cold dark
and very gentle place soon knuckle Gail
will bring me the pigment Gail when we
first met Gail in arendelle we didn't
really think too much of him he's a
soft-spoken reverent man in undying
service to his lady of the painting and
in many ways Gail isn't supposed to be
much more than just a simple undead at
the core of what being undead really
represents however saying that his two
item descriptions back then they
revealed an unusually staggering depth
to his history because Gail has been
around for a long time
he alone recalls the way of white Corona
miracle which was something that was
thought to have been lost to the ages
for long ago when the gods still had
their imprint left upon the world in
Dark Souls 1 reciting any of their
miracles would conjure up these white
disks and back then and apparently also
were these slave nights an order that
Gail was a part of and Gail's slave
Knight armor embellished with this red
cloth was once a symbol of Honor but in
stark contrast to this honor slave
Knights had a terrible duty they were
used as fodder in the bleakest of
battles imagine they were the Knights
that were sent first to tire out the
enemy because after all they couldn't
die and so we know that at least one
slave Knight outlived his masters for
while the slave Knights were never
relieved from duty Gail did eventually
find refuge in the
painted world which leads us to believe
that whatever entity they served the
slave Knights outlived them able to go
mad but unable to die my lady lives in
the cold land of Annandale I need you to
show her flame a proper flame that won't
burn the rot away and so this ancient
old undead found a new purpose one that
he believed in wholeheartedly first to
save his painted world from the tyranny
of Freda and then to help his lady
create a new world
this one painted with the dark soul of
legend and if there's any one positive
attribute to take from the dark soul it
would probably be immortality and
perhaps this will be a painting that
does not rot but it is impossible to
know exactly what kind of world will be
painted with the dark soul but I do have
faith in the good of this ending
validated by one thing gales character
because until the very end of time
Gale fights for this new world he wears
countless battles he even knows that a
terrible fate awaits him and this is a
man that's been around since the age of
five
what other character in the series can
lay claim to the knowledge that
represents so given that he has the
right to knowledge of the dark soul more
than most characters and given that he
actually told Arya to paint this world I
have to paint
I promised uncle Gayle I would and that
he expects us to be thankful in the end
you will thank me when it's done you can
conclude that his quest to find the Dark
Soul is a noble one if it is the Dark
Soul thou desirest then seek Fiona's
church at the base of the cliff there
wilt out the sleeping princess waken her
slumber is a deceit and lid covering an
overgrown privy a prop to keep thee from
the Dark Soul of thine desire upon her
awakening I expect Fillion or fully
believed that she would see the face of
her father staring back at her alas a
nun kindled wakes her from her slumber
and in a flash of light
we are transported to an apocalyptic
scene the end of the world what exactly
happens though in this cutscene is very
worthy of debate some people believe
that the entire city was an illusion and
that Fillion Orr's faith simply kept it
in check somewhat like how gwyndolin
kept the sun shining in Anor Londo but
another theory is that this flash of
light takes us forward in time to the
very end light after all is time
personally though not only do I believe
that we are transported forward in time
I think we are the only one to
experience this rapid skip forward let
me explain that so everyone else here
Gale the pygmy Lords Fillion or Shira
it's likely they fully experienced every
inexorable second of time scraping by
until this point where Fillion or
finally dies
Leonore me this the red hoodies come to
eat us to eat our Dark Souls the proof
that time has passed is in all of these
characters for example the pygmy Lords
knew that Gale was searching for them
they knew long enough that he earned the
terrifying mantle of the Red Hood the
Red Hood is come to eat us rumors like
that don't just appear in one flash of
light also gales weaponry is a testament
to time passing his blade is broken and
chipped and his crossbow is stained and
twisted they weren't like that before
and Gale himself on some level is
surprised to see that you still exist in
this world
what still here Shira however has been
looking for you I've searched for the
dark stricken creature I am Shira
daughter of the Duke descendant of gods
and trusted friend to Medea at once
I am the honor of the Gods the glory of
fire and the fear of the dark
thou shalt not go unpunished for thy
treachery thy profanity and thy
shameless yearning she too made it to
the end of the world her sole enduring
in the name of her long-lost God's
treachery profanity and yearning so
assumedly our treachery could be our
disloyalty to the gods as humans our
profanity could be the dark within us
and our yearning is the want and will of
all humans that is described in a lot of
dark eyed indiscreet
No would I ever forgive thy lowly kind
even till the end of time she never left
that dark room unaware or uncaring that
only a few dunes away the pygmy Lords
are being devoured alive by Gale the
final antagonist of the Dark Souls
series I see a lot of people complaining
that for a final boss we don't hear a
single word about this character until
the dlc of Dark Souls 3
but then is that really so strange as we
mentioned before Gale is much like us
he's a simple undead characterized by an
uncrushable resolve handed over that
thing your Dark Soul
for my ladies painting
the red hooded wandering slave night
Gale sought the blood of the Dark Soul
as pigment for the painted world but
Gale knew that he was no champion that
the Dark Soul would likely ruin him and
that he had little hope of a safe return
so why do you think he led you here to
kill him perhaps the revelation here is
that the soul can exist in the blood
which is something that shouldn't be too
surprising after all Aryan del flayed
himself to satiate a flame within a
lured vessel with his blood those that
faced upon human flesh rats in Dark
Souls one for example they've always
dropped humanity which is a fragment of
the soul and a hollow without blood
struggles to be reanimated and we
learned this in the Cathedral and the
abyss Watchers also shared the soul of
the wolfblood master between them and in
much the same way the blood of the Dark
Soul courses through the pygmies veins
yet they've existed for so damn long
that their blood has long since dried
the painter needs this blood to paint
her world but how do you paint with
dried blood well one way is to consume
it to digest it and make the blood your
own
[Music]
is this the blood the blood of the Dark
Soul
inflicted by the same frenzy that took
Manas the same insanity that took
artorias on some level Gale is still
holding true to his purpose even though
he wonders aloud whether he's succeeded
in digesting the Dark Soul and when he
sees us he doesn't see an old companion
he only sees more blood broken great
sword in hand Gale represents more than
just a part of the first DLC instead he
exists as a true counterpart to the soul
of cinder he is the desire of humanity
fighting for a place in the world he is
the frenzy of the Dark Soul he is a
hollows loss of self and he is the souls
of countless others that he's consumed
in his journey
[Music]
Gale died as he lived as a slave Knight
intended for sacrifice and in the end
whether he guided us here to kill him or
not
gales final accomplishment was consuming
the Dark Soul digesting it and bleeding
it out making the Dark Soul as whole as
it's ever been
since the very dawn of time my family's
passion one with is will I paint a world
please tell me the name hope to name
this painting after thee I see we are
much alike and I will name is painting
ash it will be a cold dark and very
gentle place
and one day it will make someone a
goodly home
I wonder when uncle Gayle intends his
return I hope the new painting will be
to him a gentle home and so a little
universe is painted within a dying world
a cold dark and gentle place like the
paintings before it except this new
world as the ineffable Dark Soul painted
into its very fabric and even when the
outside world expires whether the fire
fades whether its usurped by a lord of
hollows or an accursed undead somewhere
within the painted world of ariamis
hidden within the painted world of
Aragon del tucked away in a small attic
surrounded by a burning world is a new
sanctuary named ash maybe one day we'll
see what this cold dark gentle world is
like Miyazaki hasn't completely ruled
out Dark Souls for so I do feel like
it'll be made one day but for now and
for the foreseeable future really as you
should have expected from Dark Souls the
ending you envisioned in this new world
is all your own built upon the
excellence of your imagination I know
you still have questions
so do I soon we'll talk about the layers
of time in the Ring City the difference
between dark sigils and the dark side of
the statues of the primordial serpents
and the stories of the locusts this may
be the end for now but one day
tiny flames will dance across the
darkness I'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]